MIKE PROCOPIO: All right.
Well, good afternoon everybody,
and welcome to
Google I/O. We are grateful
to have you here.
My name is Mike Procopio.
I'm a software engineer on the
Google Drive SDK team.
STEVEN BAZYL: And I'm
Steven Bazyl.
I'm a developer advocate also
working on the SDK.
MIKE PROCOPIO: And today Steve
and I are going to help you
make your apps rock.
OK.
So we are here to talk
about Google Drive.
So Google Drive is the place
where you can store your files
securely in the cloud.
You also get for free the
fundamentals of Google Drive--
sharing, searching,
collaboration, file revisions,
organization, and even neat
little features like uploading
an image and it will
automatically do
identification of what's in
that image and make it
searchable.
All that comes for free.
With the Sync client, the Sync
program, you can keep files in
sync from your local hard drive
on your machine back
home with files in the cloud,
and the changes will propagate
as expected.
And of course, one of the key
benefits of files in the cloud
is that you can access
them from anywhere.
So where are we today, a
snapshot with Google Drive.
Millions of users have
opted into Drive.
There are more juicy stats,
but that's what we
can say right now.
And we have fully realized the
idea of access anywhere, so
that means on the web, but
also on mobile devices of
various flavors and
using Chrome OS.
We have an easy to use, fully
featured SDK software
development kit, with client
library support in eight
languages, the second version
of which we just announced
this morning--
really excited about that.
And a snapshot right now in the
Chrome Web Store, which is
where we go to find apps, we
have 50 third-party drive apps
available right now in
the Chrome Web Store.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, I think we
just added Objective-C and
JavaScript today, in addition to
Java, Python, Ruby, and all
those other guys.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Absolutely.
So, two more since V1 of launch,
since the version one
of the SDK.
Pretty thrilled about that.
So, a pretty good foundation.
So what's next?
Well, the answer is you, and our
apps, and the things that
we can do together.
That's what's next, because
right now on Google Drive we
have a pretty solid set of
built-in applications, first
class productivity apps that
offer real time collaboration,
sharing all the things
that come with Drive.
We have a word processor,
Google Documents,
Presentation, Spreadsheets,
and Drawings, the four
fundamental types that we have
right now today in Drive.
We also have the built-in Google
Drive Viewer, which
gives you a static preview
experience for lots of
different file types.
So basic things like PDFs and
images, videos and text, we
can render a pretty good
static preview.
Right here, you want
to check this out?
Here, have a look.
And we also have support for a
few proprietary formats like
Photoshop, Illustrator, and even
Microsoft Office formats.
So that's pretty great, but
it's basic preview only--
you can't do anything with it.
So here's an example of what you
can do right now with the
Google Drive Viewer on
a file type in Drive.
You can read your scintillating
scientific
publications that you keep in
Drive to remind yourself of
how exciting--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEVEN BAZYL: And that is
actually your paper?
MIKE PROCOPIO: I don't think
I noticed that before.
It might be that one time
when I was a roboticist.
That's that.
I reread it every now and then,
and man, that's boring.
OK.
So you can also-- more static
preview, preview photos of the
places you wish you were
on vacation to.
And then, of course, video
experience is very prominently
represented in Drive.
You can watch the video of you
getting second place in a 5K
race over and over again, not
because you're bitter or
anything, but that's just
what you can do.
However, the built-in
apps in that file
preview, it's just a start.
It's just a starting place.
As an ecosystem together,
we can definitely
do better for sure.
So here's a snapshot of apps
right now that are already in
the ecosystem.
Steve's been working with a
lot of these partners, and
this is where we've landed.
More on that here in a second.
So if you take away the static
preview constraint and
actually started to embrace
third party apps in Drive--
completely cloud enabled
access anywhere--
these are the sorts of
experiences that you can have.
So HelloFax is an application
that we have right
now in the Web Store.
You can do something
useful with a PDF.
You can fax it for later offline
consumption when your
Wi-Fi goes down.
You can also do things like
an e-reader could
operate on a PDF.
There's lots of use
cases here.
Another example is another app
that we partner with, Pixlr
Image Editor, a pretty robust
compelling first class image
editing app that works
on the Web.
And so you can give your
photos that kind of hip
vintage look that all the cool
kids are doing these days, and
instantly thereby boosting
your social
network street cred.
STEVEN BAZYL: And then share
them on Google+.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Exactly, and
share it on Google+, these hip
new photos.
But, of course, really we know
how you're going to use this,
and that is to create lolcat
memes early and often.
So that's what I use that for.
And, of course, with the video
experience, when you bring it
into the cloud with third-party
apps, you can do
more than just preview it.
You can actually edit it now, so
your friends don't need to
know that you got second place
in a race by one second.
You can edit it, and surely this
guy here looks like he's
winning the race.
We'll see about that.
So apps bring life
to our ecosystem.
So with apps, you can fax and
edit, render, graph, and draw
diagrams, sign and publish,
map, chart,
listen, mock and plan.
And you can do this all
right now, today, with
Google Drive apps.
And when you build a Google
Drive app, one of the key
values that our SDK lets you
bring to your users is to
integrate deeply with the Google
Drive web UI, mobile
and web clients.
And so this means that we
give apps a first class
representation in Google Drive,
from management and
viewing product details,
searching by things created
with the app, as well as the
ability to create new using
your apps, so a launcher kind
of state, and of course, the
ability to open with using your
app for the things that
it has registered for.
So you can use HelloFax
to open with
on a PDF, for example.
So Steve and I are here to help
you continue to use this
SDK and to build awesome apps.
These are vibrant and polished
apps that are first and
foremost secure, they put the
user first, and they integrate
well with Google Drive.
So let's take a quick look at
nine things that we can do
right now to get your apps
to this polished state.
STEVEN BAZYL: And I'm going to
take the first one, which is
just to talk about UX.
And this is really going to be
geared towards apps that are
document oriented.
You're building a photo editor,
a charting tool,
anything like that-- something
that fits really well within
that Google Docs ecosystem.
And I love this quote.
This is probably one of the most
probably misunderstood
and abused quotes among software
developers, at least
in my history.
Whenever we talk about design
patterns or conventions or
anything, somebody inevitably
will bring this up and say,
oh, consistency it's
not important.
That's only for stupid people.
Not true at all.
It's a foolish consistency.
It's when you're doing things
for no reason just because
they're a convention that
it becomes a bad idea.
But every platform, whether
it's Windows OS X, iOS,
Android, they all have
conventions for a reason.
It's because it makes the users
a lot more familiar and
a lot more comfortable
with your apps.
When you're not consistent,
bad things happen.
So we actually did a
little UX study.
This is when we were first
starting our trusted tester
period for Drive apps, and some
of the apps we tried were
little toy apps that
we built ourselves.
Some were actually apps from
external developers.
We put them in front of users
and asked them to do just
really basic activities
with all these apps.
And the problem was, because
there are so many
inconsistencies in how people
did basic operations, most of
the users-- in this case,
over 2/3 of them--
just got lost.
They didn't know how
to use those apps.
So this is Google Docs.
This is our word processing
tool, and it looks like any
other word processing tool,
but there's a couple key
elements I want to point out to
how the UI is put together.
So we have some really basic
information about what file am
I working on.
Imagine a text editor that
didn't tell you the file name
that you were editing--
it wouldn't be very useful.
Likewise, a lot of us use
multiple accounts, so it's
really helpful to know which
account we're locked in with.
Obviously, content--
that's the point of the app.
That's your section,
you really want
to make this great.
Navigation is always nice and
consistent up in that basic
menu structure.
And, of course, we have our
collaboration and sharing.
The cool thing is with Docs is
that I can switch over to any
of the other tools that Mike
talked about earlier, those
presentations or spreadsheets,
and I'm going to have the
exact same layout for all
of those applications.
And from a user's perspective,
that's awesome, right?
I can switch to one of these
apps, and be productive almost
immediately.
So I want to show a third
party application.
This is Lucidchart, and I think
they did a really great
job at balancing between having
their own distinct look
and feel and using those
conventions that help users be
really productive and feel
familiar with the application.
Lucidchart is a collaborative
charting tool, where you could
do flowcharts, spin diagrams,
mockups for different UIs.
We're just going to
launch this here.
And it just takes a couple
seconds to load up, but I'm
going to create a new document,
and we're not going
to give it a title.
But basically, you see here this
actually looks a lot like
any of the Google
Docs editors.
We have the same elements we had
here before-- our document
title, our file menu, our
sharing and account
information, a huge content
section, but it still is
distinctly their app.
So for building applications
that are really geared at
being productivity apps that are
meant to be complimentary
tools to the basic office type
applications, try to use these
consistencies, try to follow
these conventions much as if
you're building an app for a
mobile platform or one of the
desktop environments.
Let me switch back to the
presentation here for you.
Ooh, that was bad.
All right, there we go.
MIKE PROCOPIO: All right.
Thanks, Steve.
So one of the key value
propositions of Google Drive
is that you can access
your stuff anywhere.
Drive is fully enabled
in mobile context.
This is something that's
very important to us.
So one of the things that your
app can do to be particularly
polished is also work well in
a mobile context, which is
becoming increasingly
how we work.
And so by mobile context, we
don't mean just phones but
tablets as well--
a very exciting announcement
today.
And then Chrome OS just
recently-- we'd like to
announce that Chrome OS
has full Drive SDK
integration as well.
So here's an example of
something that works
today, right now.
So an application doesn't
necessarily have to build a
native app to have a
mobile experience.
So in this case, Aviary, which
is an image editor that's
available right now in our Web
Store, you can do basic
cropping, these sorts
of things.
It actually is an HTML5 app
that works in the Web.
So there is a native app, but
we don't need the native app
necessarily to be able
to use this properly.
So I can launch this today and
do my editing on the go,
whatever is needed, save it back
to Drive, and the image
is saved there in the cloud.
Now as it turns out, there's
also this notion of a native
experience.
These are actually apps that you
install from the Android
marketplace that sit on your
phone and oftentimes will give
a richer, snappier experience
in certain contexts that we
like to use as well.
These, as of our announcement
this morning with the Drive
SDK v2, also work with mobile,
which is very exciting.
STEVEN BAZYL: They do, and
there's actually a really
great talk.
I think it's this afternoon.
It's Alain and Claudio from the
developer relations group
on Drive are doing a talk on
how to build native apps.
MIKE PROCOPIO: And, of
course, Chrome OS.
So it's not necessarily just
mobile, but also the idea that
an app should be able to work
well in multiple contexts on
multiple form factors, ranging
from a small three or four
inch screen size to seven inch
to 10 inch tablets, including
the smaller screen sizes
associated with the most
mobile of our devices, like
a Chromebook, for example.
So here's an example of in
Chrome OS right now, which
actually natively integrates
with Google Drive and brings
those files mounted on the Web
to make them look as if they
were first class local files.
And you can actually launch apps
that you have installed
from Chrome OS and edit them
and save them back all
seamless and transparent.
So that's our mobile story.
It works today, and a polished
app should have a good
representation on a variety of
form factors for web-based,
mobile, and Chrome
OS contexts.
STEVEN BAZYL: Cool.
Thanks, Mike.
The next topic I want to talk
about is how people access
content in Drive.
So the examples you saw earlier
with the Drive UI and
how apps can plug-in
was all about
starting from within Drive.
So I'm either on my mobile app
or I'm in the web UI, and I
find a file and I click on it,
and an app magically opens.
A lot of the time, though, when
I want to access content
in Drive, I'm already in the
app that I want to use.
And there's a lot of cases,
even things like photo
editors, for example, if it's
a really, really rich photo
editing app and I can do
compositing and bring in
multiple photos, I don't want to
change context in order to
get that content in.
So what we have is a JavaScript
widget that you can
use to actually bring the
Drive UI into your
application.
This is actually just a little
screen shot here of just a
viewer for picking photos.
You could customize this Picker
very easily to fit the
context for your application.
If you're loading text files, it
may be just fine to have a
list of file names.
If, for example, your photo
editor, you want to have a
graphical view where you can
show thumbnails so people can
find their content
a lot faster.
And for those who are curious,
this is Harley Goat Farms in
Pescadero, and I highly
recommend it.
The baby goats are ridiculously
cute.
But I want to show you guys a
demo of what this looks like.
I'll switch over here.
This is just the basic
view for Picker.
It doesn't really look all that
much different than what
you would see for any other
native file system picker.
Of course, we can say Picker,
and we'll do a
metapresentation here
and present our
presentation in a demo.
If I wanted to do something
graphical, I can, again,
change this to have images.
Another cool thing you can do,
actually, though, is to let
users upload content directly.
So say you have all this Drive
integration, but it turns out
that the file that
the user wanted
wasn't actually in Drive.
It's still on their desktop.
Well, they can just switch over
to upload, drag it right
on to there.
It will upload to Drive, and
then we'll send that file
information to your app where
you can write appropriately
direct in the cloud.
So that's basically
the Picker.
It's actually really easy to use
this in your application.
So this is the code.
The first thing that you need
to do is just include our
loader script.
That's at google.com/jsapi.
That's just a generic loader.
We have to tell it to load
the Picker library.
Those are those first two
lines in the JavaScript.
Because it loads asynchronously,
we need a call
back to tell us when
it's ready to use.
That's where we'll wire up
all our event listeners.
And when it's time to actually
show the Picker and we want to
load content, we just have these
couple lines here where
we create the Picker builder,
customize which views we want
to see, whether or not we want
to support upload or not, do
we want grid view or list view--
there are a whole bunch
of options you can do--
give it a callback function,
enter app ID,
and show the dialogue.
So it's all of about five or
six lines of JavaScript to
show that dialogue and be able
to get that content out.
Really handy, and saves the
users a lot of time because
now they can access that content
whether or not they're
in Drive or in your app.
There you go, Mike.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Great
Thank you.
So earlier in the talk, we
talked about how important it
was that your app is secure.
It's perhaps the most important
thing that we can do
is to safeguard the user's data,
so we make this very
easy to do.
And the fundamental mechanism
for protecting the user's data
is this notion of scopes, or
levels of access, that your
application requests, the user
approves, and then is then
granted to your application--
for example, to access files
on the user's drive.
So once upon a time, these
levels of access were kind of
very coarse grained,
very broad.
Things had access to entire
properties or websites.
So, for example, there is such
a scope, a security scope,
that enables the application to
have access to the entire
contents of the user's drive.
Well, that seems pretty scary,
so what we've introduced as of
Version One, and then we'll talk
about it pretty heavily
here today, is this new scope
up here called drive.file.
And this means that an
application has per file
access to things on a one-off
basis based on user
authorizations in your Drive.
So let's take a look more
deeply about how
this is going to work.
Shupah!
There we go.
So this is a familiar sort
of consent page.
On your Android devices, Android
has this built-in
notion, as well.
You approve native apps for
things' access on a more
hardware system level--
access to your location, access
to the contents of the
secure digital card in your
phone, for example.
OK.
So the same notion applies
on the Web.
And here for example, Balsamiq
Mockups, which is one of our
partners, is requesting--
and it's up to the
user to approve--
information about your account,
and your email address.
And then here is perhaps the
most important request, here,
is this view and manage Google
Drive files that you have
opened or created
with this app.
So this means this app is not
requesting broad access to the
contents in the user's
Drive, but rather on
a one by one basis.
So in particular when the user
grants this scope, the app is
able to create files
in the Drive.
Also, open files that it created
and have access to
files that the user explicitly
granted.
So let's take a look at how
this works, because we
surfaced this notion pretty
prominently in the Google
Drive web UI.
For example, here is a picture
of a place that I wish I was
at for vacation, as
it turns out.
And if we click View Authorized
Apps, we will see
that currently there is nothing,
despite having
installed apps, that is able
to access that file.
So here's all the apps I have
installed right now.
OK, good.
So what I can do right now is
open this with one of the apps
that I have installed.
In this case, we will
highlight--
let's do PicMonkey, another
image editing app.
And here's the consent page--
fairly clear, basic information,
email address,
and I can expand this to see,
hey, this thing isn't going to
be able to access all the stuff
in my drive, but rather
just the things that
I tell it to.
So we're going to allow access
to that, and PicMonkey is
going to launch.
It takes a little bit of time
to first initialize, but the
picture of Napoli, a city
in Italy, comes up.
I can crop and rotate and
do all that good stuff.
But if I come back right now
to Drive, I have just
authorized that application
to that file.
So if I view authorized
apps, we will see
PicMonkey shows up there.
That is the only app that is
able to access this file, and
we want to be very transparent
about this.
And if the user wishes at any
point in time, when they're
done, they can simply revoke
it, and PicMonkey no longer
has access to that file until
the user reauthorizes it.
So I think that wraps up
the security section.
There's a number of scopes
including read-only, and the
general notion here is to
request as few permissions and
as narrow scoping as possible
that's best for you, your app,
and the user as well.
STEVEN BAZYL: Cool.
We'll do it the old
fashioned way.
MIKE PROCOPIO: That
was the backup.
STEVEN BAZYL: So another common
thing, and this is what
we think is one of the really
awesome features of Drive, is
how easy it is for people
to share content.
And for those of you that use
Drive today, you've probably
seen a dialogue like this
whenever you tried to share.
You see this inside the editors
as well, inside docs
and spreadsheets and
presentations.
You get this nice little
sharing setting.
In the API, we actually have a
really low level API as well,
that used to be in the documents
list API, is in
there and v2 of the API that
launched today that lets you
manipulate all these ACLs.
But it's very powerful and very
dangerous tools, and on
Mike's point of requesting the
fewest scopes possible in
order to manipulate the ACLs
programmatically, you have to
request permission to
all of the content
in the user's Drive.
So it puts you in a hard place
of choosing between enabling
all these features like being
able to manipulate ACLs and
share files, while still
trying to use the least
permissive scope possible that
makes sense for your app.
So we actually have a brand new
feature, and actually it
just hit production, I think two
days ago, and I actually
got a developer to implement
this in their app yesterday.
So I'm going to have
a demo of it.
Again, this is pretty much
bleeding edge, since it was
hacked together in about
half an hour yesterday.
MIKE PROCOPIO: It's
not as risky as
jumping out of an airplane.
STEVEN BAZYL: That
is true, so--
MIKE PROCOPIO: But it's
still pretty risky.
STEVEN BAZYL: The consequences
of this demo failing are not
nearly as bad, as serious.
Anyway, Loupe is this really
cool little app.
It does photo collages, and
they did a whole bunch of
integrations, such
as being able to
select photos from Drive.
So we already had a couple
in there, but let's use--
let's just add all of them.
We'll just add a whole bunch of
photos, and they're going
to import in here.
And I think they even
just added--
I don't know where it is here.
I thought they added a Google
logo in here somewhere.
MIKE PROCOPIO: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN BAZYL: Where is it?
Did I pass it again?
Oh, there it is.
So, we can arrange all these
photos in the Google layout,
which would be kind of
cool if it works.
All right, there it goes.
So this is a very social app,
and a lot of this is all about
creating these collages
and sharing--
MIKE PROCOPIO: This is why
we need third party apps.
I definitely could not have
implemented that.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, that
would've been a
stretch for a demo.
But I should be able to do--
let's just see--
in Google, and make it public.
In theory, if this still
works, it will show the
sharing things.
So the same exact dialogue that
you see inside Drive,
inside all of our editors, and
then I can just go in here and
share this with--
send it to my personal
account.
And the same flow as if I shared
it from within Drive.
The cool thing is the actual
work to implement this is
pretty trivial.
And the fact that they were able
to do this in about half
an hour yesterday was
pretty awesome.
So first thing we do, just like
we did with Picker, we
have a loader script.
It is a different one.
So if you're using both, you
have two different loaders in
there, but the rest of
it is very familiar.
So we call this gapi.load,
load drive-share.
Again, a callback for when that
library is loaded, and we
want to show it in just
three lines of code.
We build a share client
with our app ID.
We say which items
we want to share.
These do have to be items that
our app has access to, so they
have to be things that we
created or that the user
allows us to access, and then
we just show the dialog.
Super, super simple, really
great way to add that sharing
functionality into your app
with next to no effort
whatsoever.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Great.
OK, so another short and sweet
kind of tip here is to be
searchable.
Google Drive lets you find your
content very easily and
when you share your content with
other users, those users
can find it easily as well.
So for types that Google
knows about, we're
able to index them.
So Google Docs or a spreadsheet,
for example, has
keywords in it.
We index that automatically, and
when you search for that
file, it pops up immediately.
Well, it would be great to do
that for third-party apps, and
this is something very important
to us, so we
actually let third-party apps
specify every they save or
update a file.
Indexable text is basically a
list the keywords that the
user can use to find your file,
because we certainly
aren't able to decode all the
data models and the custom
file formats that third-party
apps are sending you.
So here is a short and
sweet quick demo.
Some say, I've been told, that
I have a propensity to use
kind of exciting large words,
like phenomenal, spectacular,
fantastic, and marvelous.
It is true--
I actually keep a map of them
with a third-party app called
MindMeister, but I don't
know where that is.
It's not showing up
in here anywhere.
So let's search for a
word called stellar.
There it is.
So this is my map that I keep
of all these exciting words,
so every time I need to use
one, to sound particularly
important, I can just pull it
right off of this map and I
have various synonyms that I
need on an as-needed basis.
So, here-- spectacular,
extraordinary, marvelous covered.
So because MindMeister sets
indexable text, every time
they save the file--
which we know nothing about--
we are able to search for that
and discover it very easily in
the Drive UI as needed.
You're good at that.
STEVEN BAZYL: Tab tab.
That's all I've got to do.
MIKE PROCOPIO: All right,
another backup.
STEVEN BAZYL: You have no faith
in the network, do you?
MIKE PROCOPIO: No.
STEVEN BAZYL: For someone who's
building cloud storage,
you would expect a little
bit more confidence.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Sorry.
STEVEN BAZYL: All right.
So this is another behavioral
thing with apps, and also
something we learned from doing
some UX studies, which
is autosaving.
So we've sort of trained users
with a lot of these cloud apps
now, particularly Google
Docs, that they should
never have to hit save.
They should just do their work
and things just magically
happen and it's reliable, and
it's always up to date and
always reliable.
And just to show how much people
have learned to rely on
this, that same UX study I
talked about earlier, 4/5 of
the users didn't even think
about saving their files.
They just assumed whatever they
typed in, whatever they
did in all these apps that we
were testing, it just worked.
You can imagine the
consequences, though, if your
app doesn't actually do this.
So I'm doing all my work, and
two hours later I closed my
browser, I had to shut down or
something happens, and I'm
sitting here thinking all my
content's safe and it's gone,
it's vanished.
So thinking about how to
do autosave in your
applications--
there are some complexities,
though.
Who here attended the first
talk on Drive today?
Anyone?
So a handful of people.
So there was something really
cool that was previewed in
that talk, which is
collaboration API, which is
basically operational transform
mutation-based API
for doing collaboration.
That's not something we have
ready yet, though, so when you
deal with Drive, you have to
deal with Drive in the context
of reading and writing blobs.
And, of course, if you're going
to autosave, you have to
make all these different
tradeoffs now.
If I have a small file, saving
that file frequently isn't
that big of a deal.
But as the file size gets
bigger, it becomes more and
more expensive for me to
do frequent savings.
So we have to figure out how
much quota, how much bandwidth
do I want to use, versus how
much risk do I want to expose
that user to in case anything
were to go wrong.
Likewise, the other aspect of
this is a feature of the Drive
API, which is revisions.
Anytime that you save content,
you have the choice of when to
create new revision that the
user can go back and revert
to, or whether or not you're
just going to touch the head.
So when you're doing something
like autosaving, you have to
think about what save events
are significant enough to
cause a new revision versus
which ones you only wanted to
show up as just an update
to the head revision.
If I create a new revision on
every keystroke, it would
basically render the revision
history useless.
I'm not going to sit there and
try to reconstruct eight
characters ago--
it's just not something that
would be useful for a user.
It turns out it's actually
not that hard to
get this logic right.
How you do this in your app
is going to be obviously
particular to what you're
doing, but here's just a
little JavaScript snippet that
I put together in a demo app.
It turned out to actually work
pretty well, and it gave me
what I felt as a user was close
to expected behavior and
close to how our own
editors work.
So in this case, all
I have here is
really just two things.
I have an autosaver, which in
this case is just going to be
an interval function.
It's going to run every
30 seconds.
We can tune that either way
depending on our needs.
It's just going to do a check if
the doc is dirty, I have a
chance to save, I'm
going to save it.
When it saves, it's going to
say, well, if the last time I
saved this is really
long ago--
maybe it's hours, maybe it's
days, it's time to create a
new revision.
But if I just saved it 30
seconds ago, I'm just going to
consider that the same editing
session, and I'm just going to
update the last copy.
Likewise, we can have
an explicit save
action in our menu.
In that case, this is debatable,
but I decided if
the user says I want to save
this document, I think that's
important enough to create a
new revision in our thing.
It actually turns out you can do
autosave with blobs that's
fairly reliable and fairly
frequent with actually not
that much code.
So that's that.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Great.
So one of the features that we
announced this morning, when
we went live announcing the
Google Drive SDK v2, is a new
feature that lets third-party
apps operate directly on
native Google Docs types.
And this is important, because--
and I didn't get
exact clearance on the number,
but something like eleventy
gabillion files that are native
Google Docs types are
stored in Drive.
STEVEN BAZYL: That might be a
little bit of a stretch, but
we'll get there.
MIKE PROCOPIO: OK.
We'll get there, you promise?
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
Just give us--
MIKE PROCOPIO: Eleventy
gabillion--
that's a lot of native Google
Docs types, and there's no
reason why third-party apps
shouldn't be able
to operate on those.
As it turns out, the data type
that's associated with, for
example, Google Doc or a
presentation is Google
proprietary.
It's snapshot based, there's
some logging so we can do
things like track revision.
It's a fairly intricate data
model that we don't need to
expose, but what we can do is
programmatically expose
exportable snapshots, read-only
representations of that file.
So for example, what we can do
now is a Google document has
the capacity to export as PDF.
And do we have any apps
that can read PDFs?
Sure we do-- e-readers,
faxing.
So what that means is right now
from the Google Drive UI
for apps that support it-- and
none do yet, because we just
announced it this morning, but
this is coming imminently--
you will be able to simply
right click on a Google
document or presentation or
spreadsheet and open it with
whatever apps can actually
handle the common export
functionality.
So in this case, a PDF for the
doc is able to be faxed.
And another example is that
SlideRocket has the ability to
read in Microsoft Office
presentations, PowerPoint
presentations, and our built-in
presentations editor
in the name of data liberation
has the capacity to export in
that format.
So we can actually import a
Google presentation directly
into a third-party
app, SlideRocket.
So that was announced today, and
we're very excited about
that, and that will be rolling
out very soon.
Example file formats that we
can support are, of course,
the obvious one is PDFs.
And there's a few that may not
be necessarily obvious at
initial glance.
But if you have a text editor,
there's no reason that a plain
text editor shouldn't be able
to open a Google document.
Meanwhile, if you have an image
editor, you should be
able to read this vectorized
drawing format that we do with
SVG or in a raster format
like a JPEG or PNG.
To do this, it's very simple.
You already in the Developer
APIs Console, you opt into
certain types that your app has
the capability to open,
and with the checking of this
box now, which is new, you
will automatically be able to
do this, and it will be
generally transparent to you.
You'll just have to read from a
different place to actually
get the data from the exportable
endpoint that we
give you automatically.
STEVEN BAZYL: Cool.
Thanks.
The last thing I want to talk
about is making your app
discoverable.
The reason we're all building
these apps--
not all of us-- but we want to
get users, we want to get
customers, we want them to use
our app, be productive, and
hopefully turn into
paying customers.
And they only do that if
they can find our app
in the first place.
For Drive, we do use the Chrome
Web Store as a way for
people to discover applications
that work with
Google Drive.
So, obviously, it's very
important to make sure you
have a really strong
presence there.
Actually, we can
even just go--
I think as of yesterday we just
added a new collection so
people can find apps.
And, of course, everyone gets
this nice little "works with
Drive" badge on their
listings.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Look at all
those pretty apps.
STEVEN BAZYL: I know, these
are awesome apps.
And you can see the importance
of having a fairly nice
presence versus--
not to point out any really bad
apps-- but if you don't do
a good job, you get down to the
bottom and nobody's going
to find your app.
So you really want to focus on
making sure you have a nice,
clean presence.
These are actually reviewed by
humans, the images and the
assets, and there are certain
guidelines that you have to
hit, particularly if you want
to get into any of the large
banners on the Chrome
Web Store.
So I would encourage you to
check out the documentation
for Chrome Web Store for how
to publish apps, and pay
attention to the marketing
guidelines on there so that
you have a strong presence.
But the part that is, I
think, even cooler--
and this was talked about, if I
can actually switch to that,
there we go--
is we talked about
sharing earlier.
Sharing is also an awesome way
for people to learn about your
app through word of mouth.
So this is actually a screenshot
of the previewer
that we had built into Drive.
This is what happens when it
finds a piece of content that
was created by one of these
apps, but the user doesn't
have installed.
So in this case, I might create
a mockup of the next
version of a great new widget,
save that mockup in Drive,
shares it with me,
and I get this--
I try to open it, it says, all
right, this was created by
Balsamiq, I don't have it,
let me go install it.
In fact, we can actually
even just see what
that looks like here.
Actually, I think I did this one
with a SlideRocket before.
If I click install, I'm going to
get this nice link here to
the listing, and I can
choose to install it.
Even better is content that you
already have in your hard
drive at home, on your laptops,
and your desktops and
you put it into Drive--
it wasn't created by
any of these apps.
We can actually still promote
your app based on the type of
the file, so I can go into--
let's go into Drive, and let's
use one of these Loupe images.
So down here in the corner--
it's a little small right now
and we're trying to get
them to make this
a little bit bigger--
is this little Chrome thing.
A little Chrome--
yay.
Nothing like an IM
during a talk.
Anyway, so you can
click on this.
Actually, in this case, we did
actually just launch this
feature like a day or two ago,
so there's not that many apps
that have added the metadata
yet to support this.
But what I'm going to get is
an app that can do this.
Obviously, we like this to show
PicMonkey and Aviary, and
so on, they just haven't
done their updates yet.
But I think there was in an
earlier talk for those who
went saw this with Microsoft
Project files.
There's three or four apps in
the in the Chrome Web Store
that can open up those
files very easily.
So it's a great way for people
to find your apps.
To enable Drive to be able to
promote your app that way--
there we go--
is actually pretty simple.
You just have to add a little
bit of text to your manifest
for the Chrome Web Store that
basically describes the MIME
types and the file extensions.
Actually, in this case, file
extensions are just kind of
modeled as MIME types.
In this case, I'm just saying I
can do text plain, or I can
do anything that ends in .txt,
which is that really, really
long MIME type.
And this will basically allow
us to search for apps in the
Chrome Web Store that can handle
certain content, so
that when users migrate their
files to Drive and they put
everything in there, they can
open it and find your apps to
work with those files
in the cloud.
MIKE PROCOPIO: That's great.
You know what I love about that,
is that you don't have
to go to a store
to find an app.
Actually, discovery is built
into regular work flows like
sharing and just viewing
your file.
STEVEN BAZYL: Exactly.
It's a great way to discover
new content and new apps.
MIKE PROCOPIO: So, good.
A quick recap then.
STEVEN BAZYL: Sure, I'll
hand that off.
MIKE PROCOPIO: So we've show you
nine things that we can do
here and now to make
your app rock.
So, UX matters, right--
UX consistency, user experience,
user interface
consistency, having a solid
mobile story, making sharing
super easy, security first and
foremost, the ability to open
anywhere, including opening
files from your app, setting
indexable text so you can be
searchable and discoverable
the files built with your app,
saving early and often with
autosave, opening Google Docs
types directly without having
to manually export first, and of
course, being discoverable
in the Chrome Web Store and in
our standard [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN BAZYL: The thing is not
all these are going to apply
to every app, but the idea is
these elements are things
that-- the apps are successful,
the apps are
really well polished and get
great reviews, all adopted
elements of these things.
So pick and choose which ones
apply, but a lot of things to
think about in designing
your apps.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Definitely.
Good advice.
OK.
So what next?
Well, what are you
going to build?
There are-- and I had to
get special clearance
for this one, too--
zillions of files
stored in Drive.
STEVEN BAZYL: Not quite
there yet, but close.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Let's
keep cranking--
files of all types.
Things that you would think of--
lots of images and videos
and PDFs, productivity suite
applications, text in rich
text format, plain text, ZIP,
RAR archives, and lots of
source code files,
interestingly.
So what people are doing is just
kind of blanketly moving
to the cloud, uploading
entire hard drives.
So the question is, what can we
do to bring life to these
files that exists right
now in Google Drive?
So basically we're in this kind
of new era of the cloud,
and the short story is if we
needed an app in the desktop
days, well, we're fully cloud
enabled now, and so we need it
now in the cloud.
Did you change--
that is comic sans.
That font is comic sans.
Did you change that?
STEVEN BAZYL: I may have.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Unbelievable.
This is--
STEVEN BAZYL: I am a
fan of comic sans.
I can't actually say it
with a straight face.
MIKE PROCOPIO: This is what
happens in a collaborative
environment.
You know there's a revision
history on this.
STEVEN BAZYL: There is.
So we could find out
who actually--
MIKE PROCOPIO: I'm
just saying.
We're going to find out.
But let's take this one more.
It's not just about the files
that are in users' drives
across the world right now, it's
also about experiences
that you can have, and sometimes
the file type is
secondary to the experience.
So take, for example, Desmos
graphic calculator app here.
You can actually save the
equations that you enter in
and persist them into Drive--
for example, teaching and
lectures in a scholastic
context.
But really graphing is
kind of real time--
learning about the app, rather,
learning about what
the equation does and how it
plots and what y equals 1 over
x looks like, so it's all about
the experience right
then in there.
So there's lots of apps that
are like this as well that
aren't necessarily about the
files stored in Drive, but
rather the capability and the
experience when using the app.
So we'll go ahead and start
to wrap up now.
We'll have some questions here
shortly, but let's just say
one thing I wanted to mention
is that we are here for you.
Developer advocates and
engineers, we work hand in
hand-- love these guys.
STEVEN BAZYL: We have a really
great relationship with the
engineering team.
When you guys ask a question on
stack overflow or you have
a feature suggestion, it's
basically just a hop, skip,
and a jump before it gets down
to the actual engineer who's
building it.
And, of course, you can actually
meet a lot of the
team in the Sandbox today.
We'll be there afterwards and
you can come meet both the
developer relations and the
engineering team, and I think
even a few PMs, too.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Sure.
So the short story is my job
is to make him happy.
STEVEN BAZYL: And my job
is to make you happy.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Exactly, so
you see how this works.
This is going to
work out well.
Things you can go to you right
now-- the version two of the
documentation is live and
fully squared away here,
developers.google.com/drive,
and we also
have a support forum.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah.
Stack overflow, we have a Google
Drive tag on there, and
a bunch of us on there that are
constantly answering questions.
A few of them are in the back of
the room, and we do try to
respond pretty quickly.
I think our response rate
is almost 100%.
MIKE PROCOPIO: That's
impressive.
Well, thank you guys
very much.
We are grateful for
your attention,
and thank you again.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE PROCOPIO: We would like
to open up the floor to
questions at this point.
If you have a question,
come up to the mic so
we can get it recorded.
STEVEN BAZYL: We have a little
bit of time, and if we run
out, we can take it outside
down to the
Sandbox and keep cutting.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN BAZYL: Could you turn on
the question mic, please?
Or you could just shout it
out, and we'll repeat it.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is just a little
bit about the model.
So do you have to have your app
installed in Chrome to be
a document editor?
I saw in your scenario when you
try to open up a new doc,
it suggests you install it.
STEVEN BAZYL: Yes.
Right now for integrating into
the UI, that installation does
have to originate in the
Chrome Web Store.
That is something that we've
gotten a lot of feedback on.
We are trying to make that a
little bit of a smoother
experience, so stay
tuned for--
AUDIENCE: But it is possible
to have an app that edits
documents that it just lives on
its own URL and it's your
own domain.
MIKE PROCOPIO: As of this
morning, absolutely.
An installation requirement to
use the API is no longer
present, it's just there you if
you want to integrate with
the open [INAUDIBLE] inside
the [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Cool.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: I had a quick
question about
the security model.
You're saying you obviously only
use as few securities and
permissions as you need.
I found, though, especially with
Android apps, a lot of
times developers will ask for
a lot more permissions than
you really think they should
need, and sometimes it's for
some optional feature.
Sometimes it's for something
like monetization or
advertising or whatever.
It looks like it's kind of
an all or nothing model.
There's no way I can just--
for example, the Loupe Sandbox
you showed, it's asking for
more permission than I
think it should need.
Is there any way I could say,
well, you can have these, but
not this particular one,
and try and work
without it or something?
STEVEN BAZYL: So
that's actually
a really good question.
Our [INAUDIBLE]
grant page does not allow for
optional permissions right
now, so it is one of those
things where it--
typically, the reason why you
see a lot more [INAUDIBLE]
is people want to be able to get
your identity so they can
establish an account
for single sign on.
Often they ask for
an email address.
If they're doing sharing,
sometimes they ask for contact
and things like that.
But, yeah, there's no way right
now where you can say
during one of those requests
approve all but one.
It's an all or nothing
proposition with that.
What Mike was really referring
to was within Drive, moving
from all your content or none to
a model where now it can be
just some of your content.
But what you're talking about is
a little bit of a different
problem and something
we're aware of.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious,
because basically you're
suggesting people don't ask
for the all complete
permission.
But since developers still can
do it, how does a user respond
when they want to use something
where developers ask
for all that?
MIKE PROCOPIO: We try and make
the coarse permissions as
scary as possible.
So let's chat some more.
This is a tricky problem--
let's chat some more
afterwards.
Ivan, do you have--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE PROCOPIO: Repeat the
question, I got it.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Plus one on the
last guy's suggestion.
That's a really good idea.
Similar on that same vein, is
there any desire to have the
apps be able to have permission
over a folder and
not just file specific?
Has any developers
asked for that?
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, so--
MIKE PROCOPIO: It's a
really good idea.
STEVEN BAZYL: The question is
any plan for folder scopes
instead of file scopes.
It's something we've heard a
lot, and yes, duly noted, but
I can't give you
any plans yet.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Thank you
for that question.
AUDIENCE: The indexable text, is
that just keywords, or like
for Balsamiq, that's
just a mockup?
So is that whole thing
searchable, or is it just
keywords that they specify?
MIKE PROCOPIO: In general, it's
just kind of raw text
that we accept.
We actually accept it in an HTML
based format, so we're
able to parse out URLs on
these sorts of things.
But it doesn't have to be
any specific format--
it truly is kind
of an abstract.
Here's a kind of a string field,
set your indexable text
in whatever kind of tokenized
parsable string of words that
you want, and we will index
it accordingly.
So pretty simple to use.
Thank you.
That question regarded indexable
text and how to use
it and whether we can actually
parse custom data models, and
the answer is yes,
we can do that.
AUDIENCE: Is the Drive
SDK going to be
replacing the Docs API?
STEVEN BAZYL: The question
is will it be
replacing the Docs API?
It is, as of today, feature
equivalent.
Anything that you could do
in the Docs API is now--
should be everything-- is
possible in the Drive API.
Eventually I would expect
Document to get deprecated?
[INAUDIBLE], do you know if
it's getting deprecated
anytime soon?
You would know, you're--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN BAZYL: For now, they're
both supported.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Feature parity,
it is the new API network
going forward.
Thank you.
Time for a couple
more questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Did you think about
localization, like for
example, if you have that full
text search that I can give a
hint which language that is?
Or for actions, that I can say
instead of open, what would be
the localized version of that?
Is there something in there--
I didn't have a look
at it yet, but did
you think about that?
MIKE PROCOPIO: So the question
is generally about
localization and how we're going
to support, and I heard
two questions in there that
were good questions.
The first concerned verbs
like in the "open with"
menu in the web UI.
So the short answer there is
that those things are all
translated in, I think, some
40 different languages.
The open verb itself
will be translated.
AUDIENCE: But custom--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MIKE PROCOPIO: --target of
things that you can create.
So, for example, in Balsamiq,
it's not a Balsamiq create,
you create a wire [INAUDIBLE].
That target is now or is very
soon going to be fully
localized in all
the languages.
And then I think the gentleman's
other question was
more of how can we localize
a full text search?
STEVEN BAZYL: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
To add onto what Mike was
saying, some of the widgets
that we showed, like
the Picker, for
example, you can actually--
that's fully localized.
So when you do the load you
can specify a language.
I don't think sharing is--
actually, that might render
based on the users, because we
know who the user is, so that
might actually render.
That I can find out.
A full text search is a really
good suggestion.
I don't think right now that
it will do that, but--
AUDIENCE: And for custom verbs
and targets, did you think
about that?
Like, instead of open--
I don't know, edit, would be
localized, of course, but
other words like sign or
something like that?
MIKE PROCOPIO: Right, exactly.
So the question is what kind of
verbs will show up in the
"open with" menu?
This is a classic UX tradeoff.
You create a numeration of
things you can do-- facts or
sign, as you've said.
So it's more accurate, but
there's an elegance to having
like a single--
whatever the verb is, under
an open width thing.
So there's a tradeoff here with
how fine grained we want
to get and any friction
that may bring in.
STEVEN BAZYL: Right now the only
thing that's supplied by
the developer is actually the
product name or the type of
item you're creating.
The verbs aren't customizable
yet.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Good.
Good question, thank you.
Great, guys.
I think that our time is right
on time here, so thank you
very much for your attention.
We are around here and remain
at your disposal if you want
to come chat with us.
We also have office hours
here, and great.
Thank you very much for
your attention.
We appreciate it.
STEVEN BAZYL: Thanks, everyone.